mais
les bleus ne
touchez pas à nos enfants
touchez pas
[Musique]
chez certains il ya eu d exclusion du
groupe parce que bien il ne pouvait pas
porter de masque et donc ils ont été
rangés au fond de la classe il devait
manger en fait
en différé des copains et faire la cour
de récréation en différé donc on leur a
brisé tout lien social face à cette
situation et tout ce que l'on nous
impose sans qu'on puisse être consultés
on ne sait plus comment réagir
en fait pour pouvoir sortir nos enfants
de là
[Musique]
on
peut dire que les enfants souffrent
énormément depuis le début de la crise
parce que peu importe ce qui se passe
c'est nous qui savons ce qui est bon
pour nos enfants c'est quelque chose
d'inexplicable en fait c'est une maman
sait ce qui est bon pour son enfant
[Musique]